giselle cherie's son aiden is almost
three and she has spent much of his
young life worrying about him getting
coveted and hoping for a vaccine i just
want to protect him from getting sick or
if he does
does still get sick i want to protect
him from you know any severe outcomes
moderna is the first vaccine maker to
ask health canada to authorize a low
dose of its spike vacs for children as
young as six months and up to age six
who've not till now been eligible
there's still a big unmet medical need
so i think we need we're seeing cases
and children raising so i think we need
to give the option to parents to
vaccinate their children infectious
disease doctors are delighted because
kids are at risk in the current wave of
kovid we've had a number of
kids die
and so
so that's protection of the children but
also
protection of the families the older you
are the more likely you've had at least
one vaccine dose as of this month
canadians over 60 are more than 95
percent vaccinated younger adults
including teenagers are close to 90
percent and children 5 to 11 have only
just been receiving vaccines recently
are at 57 percent but kids up to the age
of four are close to zero so vaccinating
that group can only add to the country's
overall immunity but for some parents
there is reluctance emily borghese is
vaccinated but her child is only six
months old and they both had covid i had
omicron it wasn't that bad so i don't
think she needs it it's not worth the
risk in a statement health canada says
it will only authorize spike vaxx if its
independent and thorough scientific
review of the data shows the benefits of
the vaccine outweigh the risks in this
age group the approval process could
last several weeks we have full
confidence that the application will
look at in the very best way and doctors
say if the drug is safe the greater risk
would be not vaccinating children the
risk of long-term side effects on the
kids is negligible compared to the risk
of
children getting cold and getting sick
with it and transmitting it to other
vulnerable people giselle cherie doesn't
need convincing i'm looking forward
for this to be over aren't we all
eric sorensen global news toronto